you've gone on now to build A2 million
property portfolio and you're making how
much profit a month between sort of 14
and 15K how many properties do you
personally own right now six and how
much do they cash flow eight and a half
from the properties that we own we've
then got the five rental service
combinations in cry as well and we've
also set up a maintenance and management
company do you mind that the Market's
Dro no I don't care it's an absolute
cash care that prop like if he went down
20K in value I don't care cuz I'm just
going to keep it it's going to make me
£3,700 a month don't kill the Golden
Goose otherwise you're Feast for a day
enjoy the eggs that the Golden Goose
lays where we were doing one deal at a
time and it was taking a year you know
we're now doing multiple deals at the
same time and pushed him through much
much quicker how much of your success do
you put down to the following the
training Simon auson welcome to wins on
a Wednesday oh it's great to be back
Samuel thanks for having me I met you
first maybe a couple years ago and you
were working as an engineer you were
doing all right you didn't really have
much property stuff going on at all and
you very quickly became financially free
and I interviewed you on winners on a
Wednesday about a year ago and you'd
become financially free super quick and
a lot of my audience they'll say how are
they doing now though you know they
either become financially free real fast
after a few months but then what happens
so you've gone on now to build A2
million pound property portfolio and
you're making how much profit a month so
we make about 14 15K a month um you know
from property from property yeah yeah
and last time you came on winers on a
Wednesday you hadn't quite quit your job
yet no I was still working I was still
working yeah I was actually made
redundant um I got made redundant in
January was that the best thing that
ever happened oh it was you know it's
completely transformed you know the the
business that I run now did you enjoy
your job I did enjoy my job what was you
do at the time so I was traveling around
the world setting up automated uh
warehouses you know it sounds really
glamorous I was in America France Sweden
but let's be honest anywhere you can
build a big Warehouse isn't particularly
a nice place to go I'm I thinking though
were you not helping the institution
print more money yes that was my
previous job so I actually got made
redundant from that one as well you just
keep getting made redundant over and
over it's the nature of it you know and
it just goes to show you are not safe in
any job it's true I mean my mother said
to me when did I start work 16 for a
company that manufactured Bank notes she
said Simon you'll never be out of a job
you make money for a living guess what I
got made redundant nobody uses cash
anymore cash is trash it's gone it's
gone the world changes that and you're
right people used to say back in the day
have a job it's secure well not only is
a job not secure but also often pays
terrible anyway yeah yeah I mean I bet
you're making way more now than you were
when you had a job oh three times as
much and I bet that your life is way
easier and way happier very much so I
mean it was very stressful having a um a
job at the same time trying to do
property trying trying to build a
portfolio doing refurbs now I'm in a
position you know I've got so much more
time um you know I haven't got the
stress of the job I'm not living out of
a suitcase anymore and you know it's
really enabled me to transform my
business and also spend a lot of time
giving back as well doing the mentoring
you know spending time with family which
is really good also in this interview I
want to really pick your brain about
exactly what you're doing and how people
how we can do it too how people watching
this can really learn from what you've
done learn from your mistakes your
successes your challenges and do the
same now when I had you on Windows on a
Wednesday last about a year ago you
doing okay but you was about to buy a
chapel on the be Beach which sounded
like a bizarre project the question I
got for you is did you buy it and how's
it going of course we bought it we would
have been mad not to what's it called so
it is called the Cozy Cove Chapel it is
in the aisle of Portland and it is three
meters from chz Beach no a beautiful St
property I need to stay there so it's a
chapel on the beach how much do you pay
for that in the end
237 is what we paid for it that's not
bad for a chapel on the beach it's not
bad no it's good and it's the location
as well you know you know we done a lot
of due diligence on that we understood
that there was demand in the area you
know tourism and we can charge a premium
you know it's a it's a unique property
does really well on the Airbnb listings
when you say you can charge a premium do
you mean you can rent it out for a high
amount of money yeah I think 12 months
ago you asked me on winners on a
Wednesday how much profit we'd make and
I'm sure I told you it was ,700 a month
yeah last month we made 3,700 profit on
that one property that's Financial
Freedom from one day it is it's absolute
Madness that's incredible so how much is
it worth now do you think I think it's
probably worth 237 you know we didn't do
a massive amount to it liquor paints you
bought it for 236 237 oh so you think up
in value I don't think it has no no I
think it's purely because you know the
Market's dropped slightly do you mind
that the Market's dropped no I don't
care it's an absolute cash care that
property I couldn't get less like if it
went down 20K in value I don't care
because I'm just going to keep it it's
going to make me 3,000 7700 p a month
it's your Golden Goose it is when you've
got a Golden Goose I don't know if you
heard you heard me talk about the Golden
Goose yeah so you got Golden Goose and
it's laying eggs every month you're
getting nice eggs 3,700 and sometimes
people are like I want the Golden Goose
it's not about the Golden Goose it's
about the eggs don't kill the Golden
Goose otherwise you'll Feast for a day
enjoy the eggs that the Golden Goose
lays and you've got a Golden Goose with
the chapel it's bringing you in £3,700
profit that's incredible is that like
normal though how much profit you make
on average so over the summer periods
it's 3,700 is the norm we drop down to
about 225 in the winter yeah but we
Market it very cleverly so you know the
a of Portland has got a massive dock
there um we get a lot of cruise ships
that come in there's a lot of um Olympic
sailing that goes on there but there's
also a lot of military vessels as well
um so during the offseason you know we
target the contractors that come in
there you know they're working on the
solar systems radar systems and ours is
one of the only places that has got
parking outside so when they've got all
their expensive tools in the van you
know they want somewhere to park up
we've got a camera outside you know it
keeps keeps an eye on the tools as well
yeah so it's all about that marketing
you know how do you switch that strategy
for the offseason right and how do you
change it so just being in contact with
the contractors local workers in the
area and the cruise ships as well cruise
ships come in there all year round and
they're always looking for people to
stay so so we've reached out to a lot of
them as well a little thing that we do
with our service accommodation because
we've got a lot our growing number of
service accommodation units is we call
our guests and just say how's it going
we'll ask them a few questions number
one is would you like to extend your
stay and sometimes they're like oh we
didn't realize that we could yeah we'll
extend it for another week another
question is what made you choose this
property unique properties do really
really well on Airbnb you know there's
many many standard studio apartments but
this one really stands out you know and
mostly the location you know it really
drives a good occupancy rate but when
you know why booking it then you can
mark it specifically to those types of
people oh absolutely we also have a QR
code in the property okay and the QR
code links to our CRM system and it's a
nice postar you know with a with a
picture of chazel beach we love
returning customers you know 10%
discount sign up below and um I also ask
them for their date of birth and people
are like why do you care when they're
born well I care when they're born
because everybody wants to go away for
their birthday so it means that if I
have a gap in the calendar I can go to
through my CRM system and send them a
marketing email happy birthday why not
stay at the Cozy Cove Chapel 10%
discount interesting I reckon the reason
you're making thousands of pounds every
month is because you're paying attention
you're paying attention to your
customers you're paying attention to
your marketing some people if you just
left that on Airbnb and just thought I
it will do whatever it does you might
make half of the profit but because
you're paying attention and you're
active on it that's why you're getting
so much profit yeah it's all about
treating it like a business isn't it it
is a business it needs nurturing you
know you you need to refresh refesh it
and you have to understand you know
these guests are people that you're
servicing you know you're Pro providing
a service to them and you know if you
can provide a really good service
they're going to come back is it
systemized or do you need to go visit it
when there's guests no so it's fully
systemized we have a super cleaner in
place she is an absolute Superstar you
know it's linked to the channel manager
she knows when the bookings are she
knows how to set the beds up she's got a
spare key she's even got contacts for
for maintenance people within the area
if we need anything so we very rarely go
there which is really frustrating
because it's such a lovely Chapel I
would love to go to the beach more often
well you love it so much that I believe
you're buying another Chapel down the
road the pretty much the same as this
one yeah very similar building you know
it's in a very very similar area but the
model is proven um this one's going to
be slightly smaller it does need a bit
of work on it as well so this is going
to be an off-market deal it's within
sort of a mile of the the other one
which is really good but we've got a
proven concept you know it works it's on
the beach um you know if if we can get
3,000 maybe 3,500 profit from that one
as well you know two deals that's big
big money how many properties do you
personally own right now uh six and how
much do they cash flow they cash flow
about eight and a half from the
properties that we own we then got the
five rental service combinations in
centry as well yeah and we've also um
set up a maintenance and management
company nice so yeah so how much do you
make in total then with all the stuff
that you're doing like how much is an
average a month that your whole business
will bring in in total including all the
different things that you've got going
on so between sort of 14 and 15K which
is really good that's not bad at all how
much were you making before when you
were an engineer ah good question
definitely not that much maybe 5K a
month maybe five 6K a month as an
engineering manager but so how's life
changed then since you got into property
because you you know you've been doing
this a few years now like if you've
rewinded a couple years when you were in
your job and you had one or two
properties compared to now am I right in
thinking that when we met you were
making about £500 a month in property
yeah roughly and now it's like 14 14 15K
yeah so you've like more than 10x and
how much of that would you put down to
the training CU I know you've directly
followed our training you were
introduced to us by Darren and Ella um
who also did the training and became
super successful Word of Mouth how much
of your success did you put down to to
the following the training I mean the
numbers speak for themselves don't they
I mean I started in property 2016
flipped the house you know I joined the
academy and was making maybe
,500 now we're making 14 15,000
so you know within that sort of 18
months it's just exponentially grown
it's unbelievable and that's learning
all the creative strategies you know HMO
service accommodation how to get that
super rent how to do rent to rents fast
cash deal selling you know it all comes
as a package and when you can bring that
together yeah you know it transforms
your life you've done a lot of brrs and
you're quite known for brrs you've also
got quite a few service accommodation
properties as well what do you think is
a better strategy do you think do you
think bu I refer ref Finance is better
or do you think service accommodation is
better it's a great question and do you
know what it's a question I get asked a
lot and I don't think there's a right or
a wrong answer and the reason for that I
think it depends on your personal
situation it depends on your location um
and it depends on what your your goals
and your objectives from property are so
you know I can remember you saying to me
Simon you always do slow pound you've
got to make some fast pound man yeah
yeah that was when uh we took on the
rent to service accommodations and
you're right you know just made me fast
cash because you hadn't done that on
your last winners Wednesday I don't
think you've done any no or or at least
very little compared to what you've done
now and you started with the slow pound
and I think you're right and you've
combined not just rent to rents and
service accommodation with BR but a lot
of your BR properties are brr but then
you rent them out at the end of service
accommodation because if you buy a house
for 200 Grand spend 50 on it and then
refinance it at 325 and pull all your
money out well now if you've got a big
mortgage you have to pay £800 a month
for the mortgage if your rent's only a
grand you you might have pulled all your
money out but you're not making any
profit single is absolutely dead in this
market it is hard you know unless you
can get somewhere that's really below
market value but even then you know we
talk about the mortgage but it's the
maintenance the management everything on
top of that you're not going to make a
profit so we actively Target now byof
Furbish Finance to Super rent to service
commodation all to HMO and that's where
we make the money yeah what's been the
biggest challenge in your property
business over the last couple of years
do you know what the biggest challenge I
think was when I was working for time um
it's very difficult to do to do a high
press job I mean I was almost felt like
I was on cool you know i' been to
America for three months Sweden France
you know flying all over the world whil
trying to build a property business
there's just not enough hours in the day
yeah now you know since um since I've
been in property full-time you know it's
much more relaxed you know I've got time
to work on the Strategic side of the
business and what I found is you know
where we were doing one deal at a time
and it was taking a year you know we're
now doing multiple deals at the same
time and pushed them through much much
quicker and that was what I asked you if
you could come help help with the
mentoring side of things on our property
training business because you know You'
been on Windows on a Wednesday you were
doing really well you were smashing it
and then when you got made redundant I
remember you were like oh man I got too
many now I got loads of time and yeah it
was like completely different yeah and
you were used to doing your whole
property stuff in the nooks and crannies
of life so I thought okay this guy he's
he's done really well he's making good
money in property he's been through the
training himself
good person good heart I thought maybe
you you know step in and you and you've
been brilliant what do you enjoy the
mentoring side of the business oh I love
it mentoring something that I've always
been very passionate about very
interested in not just in property you
know since you you've invited me to do
it but also on the corporate side as
well you know I've had a lot of
apprentices in my time a lot of young
technicians that I I've mentored and and
coached you know put them through
qualifications for engineering and I've
also had some really good mentors as
well um both in the in the corporate
world but also yourselves you you know
yourself Tony Russell you know the
mentoring and coaching that you guys
have given me over the last 12 months
you know I wouldn't be where I am today
you know I wouldn't be making 14 15K
profit2 million pound portfolio um so
yeah thank you yeah it's really my time
to give back you know it's great to see
all the new Academy members coming
through and um really being part of
their Journey as well what would you say
as well to somebody that came along to
some of our training came to a crash
course or whatever they wanted to go
into property but they had a demanding
job like yourself you're all over the
place and running a property business in
the UK how do you jiggle the time how do
you find the time to build a property
business whilst at a job I don't think
you have a choice you know if you're
dedicated to doing something and you're
fully committed to doing it you have to
make that time everybody's got 24 hours
in a day it's just about how you use
them hours it was difficult I mean I
bought a house when I was over in
America most difficult house I've ever
bought they insisted on signatures from
the solicitors I wasn't in the country
it was an absolute nightmare it took a
lot longer that was than was needed but
we got it there in the end you know if
you want something bad enough you have
to commit yourself you have to get it
done and you've also you brought your
father into the business so he's your
business partner now how's that been oh
it's fantastic it's fantastic he's
always been interested in property he's
always been on the property maintenance
side you know he's he's built Big
extensions for people so yeah I mean he
was working in a school as a premises
manager and uh didn't really like his
job so we've got him out the job he's
5050 with us now he heads up our
maintenance and management business
which is doing really really well how
does that work then the maintenance
business you know it sort of just came
about naturally so you know after we'
done the the two masonet we done a
massive refurb on them they were really
really run down and they got a lot of
attention you know from landlords in the
area from people that know us and
because they were done to such a high
quality we noticed that we kept getting
asked over and over again can you come
and fit a kitchen do you know anyone who
can do a barroom for me we've got an
extension that we want to get done so we
identified that you know we've got an
opportunity here because we've got all
the contacts we've got gas Engineers
electricians plumbers you know everybody
that we know it just made sense to open
that that maintenance business and
provide the services for other landlords
you know friends families and also
manage a few properties so he heads that
up now I mean he's really Hands-On he
loves it like just give him a wall to
knock down rebuild it is's in his
element and that that really works and I
mean I work with a lot of my family and
I think that if you do it in the right
way being able to bring people on the
business is quite rewarding as well
isn't it oh it is I've never seen him
happier he's in his element every day he
just gets up wants to go to work enjoys
it and he's free as well you know it's
up to him he does this job he doesn't do
this job I love the fact that you've
brought lots of strategies together
you've got rent of rents service
accommodation brr BR to service
accommodation hmos how important do you
think it is to have a diverse set of
strategies when you're going about your
property business I think it's really
important and you know the academy
almost gives you a toolbox um you know
whether it be lease options service
accommodation hmos and I don't now
specifically look for a I don't know
maybe a buer ref Finance I may look at
the property and say how much below
market value can I get it and what is my
exit strategy to push the push the value
up now I've got options I mean I could
do it as a HMO I could run it as service
accommodation I could do it as a flip
one of the questions I get asked quite
often is how do you find these below
market value how do you find a bar
Furbish finance and I have quite an easy
process so I just go on to right move
I'll type in 40 miles of where I'm
looking and I'll look for cash buyer and
every property that is a cash buyer I
know the Market's going to be limited on
there you know people are not going to
buy it with a mortgage and with the
interest rates and the media that have
scared most investors off at the minute
you can get some really really good
deals you've got the opportunity to
really negotiate them down so I would
then go out and do 20 maybe 30 viewings
and from them 30 viewings I might offer
on 50 15 properties I know that 90% of
my offers will get rejected they will
not go through because they're too low
but there's always that 10% which is how
we found the two we're doing at the
minute yeah that's really nice and if if
they've put cash only it's usually cash
only for a reason definitely maybe
there's a structal problem maybe it's
just um uninhabitable so as you say no
one else can no one can get a mortgage
on the property so you can buy it cheap
then fix the problem now you've got a
mortgageable property which you can then
sell or you can refinance at a much
higher value definitely and that's how
you build your net wealth I mean we've
got one going through at the minute uh
it's a derelict five bed in um IND dors
it now that was on the market for 295
they reduced it to 285 we've got it for
244 so we're going to do that one on a
bridge but we'll spend about 90k on that
one and we've got a gdv of 470 wow and
that's on a five bed from the bridging
company so when we get it to a seven bed
you know it's going to be an all money
out deal probably 20K out so you pull
all your money out plus 20K Y and then
how how will you rent that out as a HML
so be HML yeah so there's no article
four in the area so we'll do a um C3 to
C4 yeah we get the C4 in place for the
six bed and then we'll go C4 to sui Jen
for the seven bed seven on Suite nice
how much how much do you think that will
generate in in in Revenue it's a really
interesting one so the commercial
valuation is going to be about 475 480
which is not much more than the bricks
and Mort valuation sure because of
course it's down south you know the
yields are are very different sometimes
the commercials can be lower down south
than the bricks and mo but it gives us
options you know we don't need to worry
about refinancing it we know we've got a
good bricks and water and we know we've
got a good commercial valuation how much
you think it will bring in though each
month profit will be over 2K 22 maybe so
you only need to do one of these deals
that's it one deal like that and it can
replace an average job that's incredible
what would you say been the biggest
learning point then for you biggest
learning point I think is to be
consistent I think to start with I was
very inconsistent you know because maybe
because I I was away because I was
working all the time and I think as soon
as I got my my freedom back my time back
I was able to really push forward you
know be consistent do more viewings put
more offers in get more deals you know
so I wasn't too worried when one fell
through I guess I transitioned from
doing property part-time to property as
a business and and that was a real
turning point for me why did you get ma
redundant uh great question so it was a
technology company and you know a lot of
technology companies were really
struggling during coid and yeah I guess
they were just cutting numbers why do
you think they cut you too expensive
yeah too good to too good I don't know
they must they must have known that I
had property going on backgr they
thought you yeah are you happier now oh
much happier oh yeah as a as a person
yeah there's you know trying to do a job
and do property it's only sustainable
for so long there's only so many hours
in the day you know when you're working
every weekend every evening you're
flying here flying there but now it's
much more laidback you know I still get
I get more done in the property CU I've
got more hours but I don't feel so
stressed you know I've got my time back
which also allows me to do the mentoring
and also give back as well I mean um
we've just done a big extension on my
sister's house I I call it project
charity on our socials bless her yeah
you know that's under permitted
development as well so we're not just
adding value to our business and and
building our net wealth but also giving
back to some family that's beautiful
that's a it's great to be able to do
that as as well what would you say to
someone starting out if someone's
watching this video and they're thinking
I want to get into property I want to be
able to replace my income I want to be
able to live a richer happier life and
help my family and give back what would
you say the first step should be first
step get yourself signed on to A1 pound
crash cost it cost a pound it's just a
pound that's always there's no excuses
is there there isn't what happened when
you first went to the crash course what
did you think well I didn't actually go
to a crash course because it was during
coid so we weren't running them so I was
very much direct through through Darren
and Ella I had a good chat with Tony and
you know because you weren't running the
the one pound crash courses I was ready
to commit myself I knew I knew I wanted
to be involved in it so I signed on the
E Academy sure so it was all online
exactly that what did you think though
when you first cuz some people I think
when they first come to the training
they can't believe how doable it is it's
like oh my gosh that's how you do it and
the jigsa just suddenly properly comes
together all these YouTube videos light
yeah it is like what did you think when
it when you when you came to the
training even albeit it was online at
the time because of Co like what
happened yeah I think it was really good
I just indulged myself myself in it
because you know it was quite nice I was
working from home Co had hit so yeah I
just had weeks and weeks doing the
training trying to put it into action of
course once Co had passed Tony rung me
up and said you better get yourself to
the Live Events now so that was the real
game changer you know when you get the
the network that's around you and the
support and the introduction as well to
to The Power Team I mean I think the
academy has just grown and grown I
talked to a lot of people on on bof
furry Finance as you know and deal
selling as well how do they deal sell a
bu refurbish with Finance deal and it's
never been easier I mean last week I was
up in um up in Canterbury with a
gentleman on the academy Kane we viewed
three properties and he's a deal seller
he's looking to sell the properties two
of them were really really good
properties but the way the Academy's
evolved you know he's now had a mentor
that's gone out on the viewings with him
and that's rare that happens for the
record it's very rare he found so many
deals won a competition yeah he found so
many deals that day that's why I was
just like right coming out of you for
the day and we're going to we're going
to spend the day with you you went out
with him was fantastic but he's also put
them through our new app rate my deal
which is fantastic he's now got a really
good score on the deals it's gone
through the builders quote that we now
deliver for the for the students so
we've now got a rate my deal that's
really good we've got a builder's quote
that's really good like it can't be any
easier to sell a deal like it's all been
verified yeah it's so true I love what
you've done in property but I also think
you know when you come to the events um
one of the thing my heart is this
because I don't believe that you can
learn something without doing it I think
the only way to learn it properly is to
do it and that's why when we run the
live programs I force people to do it
I'm like here's what you do and
everyone's taking notes right now get
your phone out make a call pick up the
phone and and people are at that point
either excited or scared they're either
like yeah we're going to get to do it or
they like whoa whoa just teach me and
I'll do it next week no no no by having
you there at the events and 10 other
mentors been able to help people listen
to their calls and ensure that they are
actually doing it is really really
powerful and I think that you know
you've been a massive asset to the
community and I'm really grateful to
that what would be the one thing that
you think people do over and over that's
the same mistake that people need to
stop doing a lot of our Academy members
when they first start you know they
they're overthinking they're
overthinking you know how do I set my
business up and what sort of logo should
I have and how do I do the website when
really there should just be how do I
make money what's my strategy and the
clarity bit as well when we do the
business planning with them we try to
understand what's their goals what's
their objectives because you know if
their goal and their objective is to
leave their job and make 3,000 a month
and they're looking at a Land
Development deal like it's just not in
line with where they need to go exactly
so it's the clarity that we need to
deliver and that and that guidance
really helps them I think I think you're
right and at the end of the day property
is a vehicle and if if I'm speaking to
someone who's Premier League football
player and all they want to do is leave
generational wealth to their kids then a
Land Development deals perfect yep but
if they're working at as an engineer or
working in a factory making two three
grand a month and they don't like their
job very much they want to get out of it
a Land Development deal is going to take
probably two years and then what a big
chunk of money potentially but it's just
too slow pan they need to be doing
something faster so everyone needs a
business plan and they need to focus on
making cash and they need a network all
right man well it's been a pleasure
having you on the show final words of
wisdom for people listening to the uh to
the podcast that you would share from
your experience get involved come and
see us get yourself down to the crash
course reach out on social media you
know if you want it bad enough you'll
make it happen 100% I'm going leave a
link in the description where you can
come down Meet myself meet Simon meet
the team at the property investors crash
course tickets right now are just one
pound my business Mentor is trying to
stop me doing it for a pound Tony thinks
he mad he's like why are you doing these
for a pound you should be charging £100
pound right now it's a pound click the
link below if there's still availability
get booked on now before it sells out
and we will see you in person live at
the crash
[Music]
course